that's true doesn't matter to us at all
the one that said Jeff Bezos is
listening to this laughing yeah oh god
do you think Jeff Bezos puts on podcast
he's like what do poor people like oh no
what you're talking about TV we should
start a TV thing also thinking about him
listening to this right now yeah like he
definitely has the technology to listen
to what we're saying right now yeah he's
tapped into this somehow is what he's
watching through that camera yeah
everyone loves the TMG podcast but I get
to see it live live and they'll never
know it by way of my exclusive hacking
material that has been produced for me
by in-house developers that no one has a
clue of because I've chained them in a
basement and they make apps and things
for me for my own pleasure anyways bro
mr. BAE's us if you're listening give us
the chip yeah give it give it give it
give it give you give me I like to you
know everyone calls him Jeff Bezos but
you know his last name all is a double
entendre you know its meaning in Spanish
for us no for kisses oh so I like to
call him Jeffery kisses Jeff Bezos no
hey let's call him yeah yeah Jeffery
kisses yeah I like that
Jeff Jeffery kisses yeah yeah based on
me mr. Beasley's okay anyway no I'm
gonna mute this so bro so typically you
know a celebrity walk walks you through
the house and they tell you about this
all this mundane and rich [ __ ] yeah or
it's endearing and you're like oh as a
regular person so you know um Kourtney
Kardashian did what the rest of them do
and she did it with green screen with
just still images of her house no way
reading from a script now now watch the
if you're on audio you'll get the vibe
watch the [ __ ] pacing on this this is
the craziest [ __ ] I'm just gonna let it
run for a minute okay this is real this
is real man he's got 4.3 million views
bro just wait one second what date was
this so this isn't even quarantine this
is she just did it was four years ago
four years ago but why didn't they just
go to her house
okay weird yeah just let it rip at you
ready it gets weird yep
Kardashian and these are three rooms in
my home
my name is Moulton Lawrence Bullard and
I'm the interior designer we're gonna
check out eight to seven things in these
rooms first of all we're gonna check out
exactly 87 things I said I was gonna let
it play but I just got exactly 80 70s in
this house
now do when you hear that what do you
think they're gonna talk about what 87
things pick one that you think they're
gonna discuss just the tiles on the
floor
okay what's another what's another thing
you think architecture the okay how they
designed it a furniture yeah why they
chose it come to my entryway frame
doorknob and lock in front to home my
mirrors our vintage Belgian Kendall Mira
in dog I'm not frame above a light
fixture vintage found in parents are not
shape or bear so that this table was
custom-made for me by an artist in
Venice California
James DeWolf made of concrete what's
with his voice dude why is it why is the
audio so bad dude this feels like a
[ __ ] QVC segment yeah and bro how
much he doesn't give a [ __ ] you now he's
ad libbing all this [ __ ] death tamal is
me bad guy in Venice
Jean Cousteau fortified wood and
refurbished steel I will say she sounds
like that all the time
no she does he sounds like she doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything ever I know
and I know that's the meme for her but I
mean to just the juxtaposition of like
her reading from the script yeah why
when sable was designed to me designs
for me from an artist in Venice
California
great next line these store handles are
super good for opening the store
awesome Courtney next line this kitchen
table it's made of metal I love having
sex with older women
she's like the same give grandma some
good dick it's like the same that's the
architecture all the pieces and then
just one of them yeah I love any
sectional or one death plant Brad this
fit I got this book from my dad's house
Japanese greens add some life christine
lee ultra stools why is this voice
stereo in both of my ears I don't know
and I don't know why like this is
hilarious instead of it this is it's
just so like if you come in here you
can't film it you can take pictures of
stuff but don't you [ __ ] dare ya film
anything yeah yeah yeah wait watch this
attempt at a joke
goodness all of this resting on a
limestone you nailed one what tiles and
the thing yells on the floor and I love
having my kids toys everywhere
[Laughter]
don't brushed stainless Dookie just hit
with maybe it's funnier to me though
then it is but just like how hyper-focus
this [ __ ] is you're like oh man I can't
wait to see this house grapes Venetian
shipped in from Rome okay that's not
really what I was thinking yeah yeah I
don't the grapes sink head dude this is
like shopping with your parents like an
Ikea when they're like oh we need a new
flight for the yeah this and that you're
like it's also it's also like how much
is missing from the normal series where
they actually go to the houses and they
the people lead them through the [ __ ]
like this is such a bad attempt at just
hacking it together you're hacking it
together with an you know single leave a
mix of blood spray skulls in covenant
gift it to cool
nice nice sick flex gifted to cool me
gets a [ __ ] about how how much it was or
where they got it it's gifted to code
names do cool play Confucian look here
we go let's get one more
even though some of it is out of season
she said quirky man ah she's so quirky
Bollywood saw a [ __ ] tea kettle oh
man I gotta say though that's a sick
kettle maybe I shouldn't say is in the
cups right there look at that maybe I
shouldn't say this is great a cringe but
it just it it killed me
this whole segment killed me yeah I mean
it's just it's just more of this let's
see if there's anything else in there
from sulu term still range another
with red knobs and williams-sonoma
spices [ __ ] serious williams-sonoma
spices why are you flexing that that's
not even a flex we can all get that
right now
I need that the most asinine flexes yeah
but does your stove have red knobs I can
paint them [ __ ] yeah jokes unbelievable
I was joking about there's some grapes
and they actually showed artichokes in a
porcelain bowl I was [ __ ] kidding and
they did a tear fish ulta jokes in a
porcelain bowl that's how I have that at
my place who did they make this for yeah
like someone's suffering in a [ __ ]
underdeveloped country yeah look at what
we have we have stoves with red gnomes
and food what a weird flex we have
better food than you yeah fresh
vegetables from the local farmers market
great simple single oh no wow they
actually did it dude I promise you I
didn't know that they're Amish do I only
watch about a minute of it I got up to
the [ __ ] what did I get up to it was
like um it was it was like right around
the [ __ ] a sink head is where I
tapped uh how is that a constant like
design I was at like a major design
feature of this house grapes and a
porcelain bowl and artichoke in a
porcelain bowl you think like when they
forget to when whoever the housekeeper
forgets to replace and she's like grapes
dude imagine being the architect me
email you oh yeah Architectural Digest
is gonna do a segment according so I was
like oh wow that's really awesome I'd
love to give and like know the designer
is gonna handle it he's like oh alright
I mean you don't really like make the
house but I guess yeah and he's just
highlighting all these [ __ ] things
yeah I picked out these other jokes
that's more contributions to the house
Chloe got me this Kelly worse level for
my birthday the kids and I love to pick
oranges from our tree maple cutting
boards custom steel door frame a Toki
door from the previous owner no wait
there's a doggie door from the previous
owner that's so interesting
oh those really good timin Eric yeah it
really does just do be so funny if they
started just going into like weird just
bunched up toilet paper from that's what
Becca did on the SNL did a parody of
this and it was actually kind of funny
BEC was doing that Shay like he goes in
he's like yeah this is um a window
there's like tape this tape on tape on
it there's a piece of tape on there then
it cuts like that bad bad there's
another window there's my neighbor's
blue car this is like a thing this is a
pile of paper you guys ever have paper
and he's like you don't know yeah and um
that's so good cuz that's really what it
is no it is what it is it's just
everyone's house so it's just if there's
some random [ __ ] here that I haven't
moved for two years and that's just
gonna stay there forever and I don't
even know what the [ __ ] it is couple
bills I love when they come across
something that's really expensive and
they don't know how to explain it
without coming across like an [ __ ]
yeah yeah exactly
again this is a how do I say this
um it's custom steel made by kids and
it's like kind of illegal but the knife
is like so sick and it cuts really cool
yeah yeah to come to the celebs defense
yeah it would be hard to be Aaron Paul
and describe his fireplace yeah I'm
really proud of that fireplace and you
paid a lot of money for it how do you
not describe that like a [ __ ] yeah
that's that's probably his tone is less
imported from Spain I'm sorry he was it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] to get here and we
finally got it here and I paid so much
money I have to [ __ ] tell you that it
was imported from Spain alright so what
so if I can sue me that's that's
everyone's misinterpreting his tone
that's his whole tone is like reluctance
it's not trying to be an [ __ ] yeah
you know it and the [ __ ] he's like
he's sitting there like quietly like did
you guys just ask about like
like what her favorite like hiking trail
is or something or like about the trees
yeah yeah baby we don't know the prompts
like you keep picking like the [ __ ]
hardest thing in the room could be the
producer being like this is a great
fireplace tell us about this he's like
oh yeah you know we'd like to have
marshmallows no no the stone like
where'd you get it yeah okay it came
from Spain I'm Spain how did you get it
you know it's just you know it's it's
it's just good a charter a custom Airbus
that deals specifically with moving the
cargo plane this type of stone because
it's like religious and the local
government doesn't let you have it
unless it's transported by this
particular airlines are the only one
sanctioned by the Pope to move this
stone can we just talk about something
else I love paper on the [ __ ] table
you want to know about this yeah oh is
this tell us about this oh [ __ ] that's
an offer it's a hot damn it's an offer
for a new show I can't talk about that
we'll talk about it but what could you
give the fans just like a little
what's the fee doesn't be so you're
making it like I'm not trying to talk
about this stuff but yes it's 64 million
dollar than his girlfriend keeps trying
to bail him out when she's like oh you
know it's um he let's talk about this
this is Aaron's favorite checkerboard
that we bought from a local man for $10
he's a yes yes I love sitting here
playing checkers with her in the morning
when we eat breakfast this is such a
great view did this hiking trail and
river come with the property she's like
well not not per se it had to be built
their their custom but we he's like we
[ __ ] did it we did it
wait custom whatever and we wanted a
custom hiking trail so we contacted the
city and we got our own but but you know
the land people in Utah
told us or NIDA hoe told us that this
would have happened anyways through
erosion and stuff so we were just
speeding speeding it up yeah so is
anyone else will had to walk on it
No
oh is that bite we paid to have it to be
to ourselves got it yeah they're gonna
love it
perfect that's a wrap thank you so much
Aaron [ __ ]
that's why Courtney did it this way
she's like I'm not looking like an
[ __ ] yeah pick the most boring things
in the house what's your favorite things
I love the artichoke what else the
grapes are cool yeah now that I think
about it I'm an [ __ ] because I watch
this and I expect them to be humble but
it's like how can they be yeah I know
how can they be yeah when you're just
when you're everything in your place is
riches fun oh when it's all of its
absurd yeah you know and and they kind
of [ __ ] you know this is this is
Dateline for celebrity possessions okay
you know they're taught they're chatting
it up with the producers I can't we just
want to know about your houses it's
gonna be totally cool just totally just
totally calm just you know just me and
you it's gonna it's gonna be cool it'll
hang you know maybe we'll film it who
knows we just do a little segment is
like okay yeah for sure oh come on no
come through no and then Aaron Paul goes
walking up the driveway
they let him in and then boom the
cameraman come out of the grass the
plants Chris Hanson comes flying in said
why don't you so so Aaron tell us more
about how you got this car why don't you
take a seat and then tell us about the
scene do your friends know that you
import your seats do your fans know that
you import your seats oh no I don't
really
well how about you tell them over here
we have a camera over here anyway
hmm it's kind of funny what if they
bring back Dateline what Sean Evans is
the host all right Mike you've made it
through our pedophile questionnaire
camera here camera there say whatever
you're working on tell me what you're
working on you got 20 seconds I'm
innocent
I didn't know
you